[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans ce
débrief des questions au gouvernement
séance un peu particulière aujourd'hui
séance marquée par les nombreux hommages
rendus à claude goasguen le député les
républicains de paris est décédé la
semaine dernière après avoir combattu
pendant plusieurs semaines le
coronavirus séance marque et donc par
les hommages d'edouard philippe de
damien abad et de richard ferrand une
vaste culture une liberté de ton
allié à une totale indépendance d'esprit
le goût du débat et la passion de la
politique
tel fut le député claude goasguen
mettant son savoir d'historiens du droit
au service de la représentation
nationale
notre hémicycle est orphelin orphelins
suite à la disparition de notre collègue
et ami claude goasguen
c'était surtout un homme droit et un
député qui faisait honneur à la
politique sa disparition tragique
après avoir lutté avec tant de force et
de courage comme vous le rappelez
monsieur le président nous rappelle
combien nous sommes vulnérables face à
une épidémie de cette ampleur et de
cette violence
quelle personnalité truculente cultivés
à la fois fine est parfois brutale
il en avait du panache c'est
probablement le plus bel hommage qu'on
puisse rendre de dire voilà quelqu'un
qui s'est tenu debout et qui a défendu
ses idées alors je veux m'associer à ce
que vous avez dit monsieur le président
rabat
très vite la politique a repris le
dessus avec de nombreuses questions sur
cette crise sanitaire mais aussi
économiques liées aux os coronavirus
pour l'instant le déconfinement se passe
plutôt bien du coup certains députés
aimerait accélérer le pas c'est le cas
notamment de philippe vigier il nous
faut désormais continuer d'apporter des
réponses concrètes puissante à la
hauteur des conséquences désastreuses
que va continuer à les produire cette
crise et penser dès aujourd'hui la
troisième étape de déconfinement clos
donc vous poser trois questions précises
à quelle échéance
envisagez-vous une reprise de ses
activités dans les conditions normales
ensuite allez vous mettre en place des
aides ciblées
l'exonération de charges pour les bars
les restaurants enfin alors que
l'interdiction des circulaires a été
levée partout en france allez vous
supplie mais ce décret qui limite de
manière incompréhensible le transport
aérien entre la corse et le continent
mettant à mal l'économie corse d'abord
nous avons pris des mesures pour
permettre aux acteurs de passer l'étape
et nous avons indiqué le ministre de
l'économie et des finances le secrétaire
d'état auprès du ministre de l'europe et
des affaires étrangères tous les membres
du gouvernement tous ceux qui
s'intéressent à l'avenir de ce secteur
ont dit que ces mesures avaient vocation
à durer jusqu'à la fin de l'année nous
voulons continuer à aider ce secteur
pour qu'ils puissent passer cette étape
très difficile quand est ce que les
conditions seront redevenues normales
vous me posez une question monsieur le
président à laquelle je peux
difficilement répondre je peux indiquer
ceci que nous avons toujours procédé par
étapes de trois semaines et que donc si
tout se passe bien ce que nous espérons
ce que le passé récent nous laisse
espérer alors le 21 juin le 22 juin on
pourra peut-être je l'espère dans les
zones oranges recommencé à fonctionner
comme aujourd'hui on fonctionne dans les
zones vertes
vous allez poser une question sur la
corse le décret sera corrigé dans le bon
sens dès ce soir un premier ministre
prudent donc qui préfère avancer pas à
pas mais face à lui il y à une
opposition qui souhaite voir des
résultats concrets et rapides pour
relancer l'économie
écoutez la question de la présidente du
groupe socialiste valérie rabault qui
s'inquiètent de l'ampleur de la
récession
ce matin le ministre de l'économie et
des finances a indiqué s'attendre
une chute du pib de 11 % pour 2020 quels
sont les secteurs pour lesquels vous
estimez qu'il n'y a pas de redémarrage
de l'économie à ce stade et qui ne
seront pas au rendez vous en décembre
2020 et janvier 2021
je vous remercie nous allons connaître
un ralentissement économique nous
connaissons déjà en vérité un
ralentissement économique massif
reconnaissait avec moi madame la
présidente que je n'ai jamais fait
mystère de ce que je pensais que le choc
serait massif
je ne sais pas dire madame la présidente
quel sera l'impact de cette décroissance
momentanée
l'objectif du gouvernement c'est
d'essayer de faire en sorte que ce choc
soit le plus rapidement absorbée alors
vous avez des économistes qui vous parle
d'un pacte en v2 courbe en l ou de
courbe en u
tout ça est admirable la vérité c'est
que nous devons tout faire pour que
l'attractivité économique de notre pays
les investissements là consommation
puisse repartir
et comme nous avons besoin d'une très
forte incitation publique pour que tout
ça reparte
nous devons mettre dans cette incitation
publique des choses à quoi nous croyons
faire en sorte que l'investissement qui
doit repartir soit plus vert qu'il
n'était faire en sorte que la
consommation qui doit repartir soit le
cas échéant et dans toute la mesure du
possible plus responsable que ce qu'elle
était parmi les secteurs les plus
touchés l'industrie automobile notamment
le groupe renault dans son plan
d'économies dévoilées la semaine
dernière l'avenir du site de maubeuge
semblait incertain
la députée udi béatrice descamps a donc
voulu en savoir plus le lancement d'une
concertation pour étudier la création
d'un pôle d'excellence optimisée des
véhicules électriques et utilisait et
utilitaires légers dans le nord de la
france laissait craindre une mise en
danger sur le site de maubeuge 2006
emplois directs cdi 900 emplois directs
cdd et intérim et des milliers d'emplois
indirects chez les sous traitants en
sambre avesnois
nous savons depuis ce midi que certains
engagements ont été annoncés ce matin
lors d'une réunion dans votre ministère
vous avez rencontré et écouté les
salariés les élus de maubeuge
pouvez vous monsieur le ministre
préciser ici
le contenu de ces engagements et la
manière dont ceux ci pourront être tenus
je vous remercie
qu'est ce que j'ai ressenti en écoutant
les représentants des salariés de
l'incompréhension et de la colère de
l'incompréhension parce qu'il représente
un site vous l'avez très bien dit qui
est un des plus productifs en europe au
bout d'une heure et demie de discussions
nous avons répondu à cette inquiétude et
nous avons trouvé un accord avec la
direction de renault avec les syndicats
pour que sur le site de maubeuge
l'emploi et les capacités industrielles
soient préservés au delà de 2023
qui était la fille date fatidique qui
inquiétait les salariés et qui
inquiétait leurs familles la discussion
va s'ouvrir dès la semaine prochaine
pour regarder toutes les options
une fois encore dans le cadre de cette
garantie sur l'emploi et sur l'activité
industrielle au delà de 2023 sur le site
et je me suis engagé à voir un nouveau
rendez vous en septembre avec l'ensemble
des participants à cette réunion pour
que chacun soit rassuré mais
l'annulation du nord un site
d'excellence pour renault voilà c'est
tout pour ce débrief les questions au
gouvernement revienne la semaine
prochaine
d'ici là prenez soin de vous
[Musique]